Siri what's a must no that's a month
dummy hey guys it's me Abby Shar from
Abby's kitchen so as you can tell we are
weeks potentially days away from meeting
baby and that means I have a lot of work
to do in the kitchen when it comes to
batch cooking so today I'm going to
share with you three awesome sheet pan
dinners that are so healthy so balanced
they require one pan to clean not a
whole bunch because lord knows when
you're pregnant or with child nobody
wants to have to clean more than one pan
so these are no fuss no muss whatever
masses we don't know we just know we
don't want a whole lot of them but
they're gonna be awesome for welcoming
babies so let's do this
first up my vegan chickpea and
cauliflower sheet pan meal to bowl I add
some maple syrup pomegranate molasses is
at our harissa and olive oil and I give
it a good stir then I add a pinch of sea
salt and black pepper and stir that up
as well then to my sheet pan I add some
cauliflower florets sweet potatoes
canned chickpeas and of course all that
sticky glaze give it some sea salt and
some black pepper
and I toss everything together to coat
it Nestle in some lemon slices
and then pop the whole thing into a
425-degree oven for about 20 minutes to
finish off I add some pimento olives and
pomegranate arrows and enjoy
[Music]
next up my shrimp stir-fry sheet pan
meal football I add some hoisin sauce
tamari sesame oil honey Chinese
five-spice ginger garlic cornstarch sea
salt and black pepper and I stir
everything together then to my sheet pan
I add some broccoli floret lots of
colourful bell peppers my shrimp and of
course our sauce give everything a nice
toss to make sure all of those flavors
are nice and coated and incorporated and
then pop the whole thing into a
425-degree oven for about 12 minutes top
it off with some black sesame seeds and
white sesame seeds and enjoy
[Music]
finally my buffalo chicken fingers sheet
pan meal twit ball I add some flour sea
salt and black pepper and I give it a
stir then to another bowl I add some
melted butter some Frank's Red Hot Sauce
some minced garlic and some beaten eggs
and I give that a stir
and now it's time to bread I dip my
chicken tenders into the bowl of flour
and give them a nice coating then they
go into the Franks red hot sauce egg
mixture and then finally they get coated
in some panko breadcrumb place the
chicken tenders onto a lightly greased
baking sheet and set that aside next to
a ball I add some carrots and celery
with a little olive oil along with some
sea salt and black pepper then I give
that a good toss and I place them onto
the baking sheet with the chicken place
that into the oven at 425 degrees for
about 20 minutes until it's fully cooked
through I like to finish mine off with a
little drizzle of Greek ranch dressing
enjoy
for all of these meals I like to make a
big batch of my favorite green like rice
or quinoa and then divvy them up into
individual freezer containers to rewarm
throughout the week alright guys my
freezer is all packed and ready to go
with some awesome well-balanced meals I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below with some of
your go-to freezer friendly batch meals
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye
[Music]